our nation's supply of baby formula has
fallen by 40 percent this is now an
acute problem throughout the united
states and after several days of
stonewalling the white house is finally
weighing in on it
who's running point on the on the
formula issue at the white house you
mentioned the white house as well i mean
i i at the white house i don't i i don't
know i can find out for you and get you
a person who's running point um but i
don't have a person
yeah i don't okay and maybe i the
starving babies you want to talk about
sure yeah i guess i can ask that's
karine jean-pierre the incoming white
house press secretary who already has us
longing for the days of jensaki i would
gladly take endless circling back over
laughs and giggles and guffaws at
starving babies any day but it looks
like we have already identified the
white house point person on baby formula
looks like the person who is the point
person is the secretary of homeland
security according to republican
congressman kat kamik
absolutely have to share with you right
now is the craziness of the empty
shelves biden movement and the fact that
they are sending pallets
pallets of baby formula to the border
meanwhile in our own district at home we
cannot find baby formula this is a
picture from a target
oh it's upside down sorry okay
we literally are struggling to find
baby formula around the country moms are
struggling going from store to store to
store and then the stores are actually
capping the amount of baby formula that
they will sell them but and this got
sent to me by a border patrol agent this
morning and said this is disgusting
you will not believe this they're
receiving pallets and more pallets
of baby formula
at the border this was taken at ursula
processing facility where thousands
are being housed and processed and then
released subsequently into the united
states
this is so deeply offensive
the white house is sending baby formula
to foreign nationals who are in the
process of breaking our laws while
american mothers are driving for hours
to try to find
some for their own babies
i'm not suggesting that we let the
little illegal alien babies starve
but to give the baby formula to foreign
criminals before law abiding citizens
how what are we going to do how about we
expeditiously send the illegal aliens
back across the border to their own
countries so that they can get what they
need over there
this administration is pursuing a policy
of completely open borders the largest
migrant influx in history so that's
probably not going to happen fine
then if the biden administration is just
going to release the illegal aliens into
our country why doesn't he at least do
it quickly so that they can get online
and buy baby formula like all the actual
americans why do they get to cut the
line
why is biting giving special priority
diverting the american supply of an
essential product
to foreign criminals and away from his
own citizens two reasons one our ruling
class hates its own citizens
if starving our own babies doesn't prove
that to you i don't know what will and
two
our rulers think they can get away with
it because they think that they will
never have to answer to the citizens i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from thought
criminal who says david's answer of i'm
not a lawyer is just as feeble as
certain women who say she is not a
biologist when asked what a woman is yes
i thought that was a pretty weak answer
too
but it did satisfy the point that i have
at least in bringing liberals on the
show which is i i do not generally bring
the libs on the show to own them with
facts and logic though sometimes that
happens as a byproduct i bring the libs
on the show
to hear
the opposing view i want to hear the
strongest version of the opposing view i
want to see if i am just deluding myself
in an echo chamber or if they've really
got some strong argument against me so
when
when david comes on the show
very kind of him to come on and he says
what the protesters are doing outside
the supreme court justice's houses is
not illegal and then i say no it is
illegal actually i'll cite you the exact
statute it's 18 usc section 1507 and he
says well i don't know i'm not a lawyer
uh but so i don't i don't believe you i
don't believe that statute i
that's fine we don't really need to talk
about it much further than that
when when one says i'm not a lawyer i'm
not a biologist right
what that what that person is expressing
whether it's david or whether it's
katanji jackson is
you got me you got i don't i'm not going
to give an answer here i alright
whatever moving on so
that that confirms something that i had
already suspected but i'm glad to know
which is
the libs have no defense of this and
david actually had the honesty to say
yeah i'm not
i do not encourage democrats to do these
there's there's no there's no defense of
it legally
politically it's just a big big mistake
it's just wrong and the libs should
absolutely admit it okay
now when you want to
engage in these kind of conversations
not just virtually but in person you got
to check out
daily wire backstage live at the ryman
auditorium in nashville june 29th it's
going to be a ton of fun we will see you
there and in the meantime you can talk
to me you can talk to me
through my
voicemail bag with puretalk right now go
to puretalk.com use code knowles podcast
verizon att t-mobile they're making it
clear they care more about wokeness than
wireless and they are making you fund
their agenda with overpriced contracts
and hidden fees why are you still giving
these people your money i have great
news for you you don't have to trade in
what you believe to get good phone
service you can choose pure talk instead
just like we here at dw are offering
alternatives to woke media woke
entertainment puretalk is offering
alternatives to woke wireless networks
pure talk ceo is a us veteran their
service team is located right here in
the us of a you will never have to
compromise on service because you will
be on america's most reliable 5g network
for about half the cost you can get
unlimited talk text and 6 gigs of data
for just 30 a month
there is no reason not to switch
switching is super simple you keep your
number you keep your phone or you can
get a huge discount on the latest
iphones and androids they've got a
30-day risk-free guarantee you've got
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com shop
for the plan that's right for you that
is puretalk.com use code knowles podcast
to save
five zero percent off your first month
code knowles podcast
k-o-w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
all one word puretalk.com puretalk is
simply smarter wireless go check out
puretalk today
all of these things that we that were
called conspiracy theories
weeks ago months ago within the last two
three four years
turns out
that they're all true the food shortage
was one of them they said oh there's no
food shortages don't worry about any of
the problems that the food plants it's
all a conspiracy theory well it doesn't
look like a conspiracy theory now forget
about a food shortage we're talking
about food for the most vulnerable
people
among us
and and what do does the white house do
they laugh about it they fall and they
giggle
do you remem my other favorite
conspiracy theory this one i think the
white house thought they were just going
to brush this to the side and and ignore
it do you remember was it a month ago a
month and a half ago
when the biden administration said that
they were going to send out
drug safety kits to
a bunch of drug addicts around the
country
they said that they were going to send
out
drug safety kits that included crack
pipes and we said hold on these things
include crack pipes you are you're using
taxpayer dollars to send crack pipes to
crack heads and they said we're not
that's a crazy conspiracy theory what
are you talking about that the white
house is still maintaining that position
said in february that no money from a 30
million dollar harm reduction program
would fund distribution of crack pipes
in safe smoking kits the washington free
beacon reported that they went to harm
reduction facilities in five cities and
all
of those facilities had crack pipes in
their kits
hhs would not say which uh programs had
applied for funding and the recipient
list is not out yet so i'm just
wondering if the white house can say
if any taxpayer dollars paid for these
craft pipes no federal funding has gone
to it and is there any oversight to
ensure that when that money goes out for
the program that these organizations
will not use federal dollars for crack
pipes
this policy does not allow for crack
pipes to be included i would just note
that this is a bit of a conspiracy
theory that's been spread out there it's
not accurate there's important drug
treatment programs for people who have
been suffering from what we've seen as
an epidemic across the country and money
is not used for crack pipes
this is a conspiracy theory it's a total
right-wing conspiracy theory did you
hear the question though
the question was the washington free
beacon has gone out to cities all around
the country to lots of these drug
centers the likes of which will receive
the government money to create these
exact sorts of kits and they have crack
pipes in them just like i said when this
story first came out when the story
first came out i said they're obviously
funding the crack pipes
and they said no no that's not true and
i said well i just googled safe smoking
kit and you saw all the fact check left
wing articles no safe smoking kits don't
include crack pipes so then i i changed
the search parameters and i said
okay only show me results up until a
week ago before this scandal broke for
the white house what is a safe smoking
kit and then what do you know the
results all show crack pipes
because how could you have a safe
smoking kit that does not include
something through which to smoke the
point of a safe smoking kit quote
unquote safe smoking kit is
to give
crackheads the materials that they need
to smoke
if a safe smoking kit does not include
something through which to smoke it is
by definition not a safe smoking kit so
the washington free beacon has this
great
story out
uh they
went up and down the east coast
they went to boston new york city
washington dc baltimore richmond
virginia they went to
every single organization that they
could find that gave out the same
smoking kits they all had crack pipes
and
what happened
that
they wouldn't answer any questions about
the program and jen saki says no no
nothing to see here ignore ignore ignore
it just
they're never going to admit when
they're in the wrong so the fact that
they can't come up with a better answer
gives you everything you need to know
it's kind of like when i talked to i
talked to david pakman yesterday on the
show and he said it's not illegal to
protest in front of judges homes and i
said well here's the law here's the
federal statute 18 usc section 1507
says explicitly it is illegal to protest
outside of the judge's homes and he says
well no
no i don't look i don't know i'm not a
lawyer
you know i'm not i'm not a biologist i'm
not a lawyer so
the white house is not going to
admit this the the prominent democrats
are not going to admit when they're
wrong but the very fact that they can't
come up with an answer gives you gives
you everything that you need to know
tells you that we were right not a
conspiracy theory at all you know
another conspiracy theory is that the
schools not just colleges and high
schools but middle schools and
elementary schools are indoctrinating
our kids into weird creepy sex stuff
that's a conspiracy theory it's not
happening
it's good that it is happening they tell
us but also it's not happening at all
well
i have a report out from the daily
caller maryland elementary school
invites kids to pledge allegiance to the
pride flag
in elementary school
pta invited students to be recorded
pledging allegiance to the gay pride
flag according to a post on the school
pta page
this is the montgomery county public
schools cedar grove elementary school
they announced that the school quote
will be celebrating love respect and
tolerance with a video compilation of
students holding the pride flags and
saying the words love respect freedom
tolerance equality and pride
the conservatives some conservatives are
going to say this is crazy this is nuts
get get all the sexual talk out of the
schools get all of the talk about belief
systems out of the schools get all the
religion get all of the values get all
of that out of the schools but of course
that's not possible
it's not possible to do that
because there's no such thing as
neutrality and education doesn't happen
in a vacuum the whole point of education
is that you teach people things not just
reading writing and arithmetic but about
what's good and what's bad and how they
should behave and what's normal and
what's natural and the kind of behaviors
that they should pursue frankly even the
conversation about sex education it
doesn't always have to be the creepy
stuff that they teach in the modern sex
ed classes even when when a teacher
reads a little book about mama bear and
papa bear and little baby bear they are
teaching you something about family
about about sex actually they're
teaching you something about the way
that that boys and girls and men and
women relate to one another and and so
no one would object i mentioned this on
the show a few weeks ago no one would
object to a kindergarten teacher reading
their students a story about mama bear
and papa bear and baby bear we would all
object to a teacher reading his or her
students a story about mama bear and
papa bear and papa bear's boyfriend and
papa bear's boyfriend's three-legged
goat that he has a relationship with we
would all object to that because it's
the substance that matters here the kids
are going to pledge allegiance to
something
they can either pledge allegiance to the
american flag and traditional american
views and beliefs and traditions or they
can pledge allegiance to the cultural
revolutionaries and the gay pride flag
and diversity equity
and inclusion and all the cultural
radicalism but you've got to pick one
they are going to believe
something
and right now because we all believe all
sorts of crazy stuff our economy is
going to pot which is why you've got to
check out birch gold
text knolls to 98 98 98 it happened it
finally happened the fed has realized
the dire straits that our economy is in
thanks to our loose monetary policy
turns out you're gonna be shocked to
hear this you can't just spend trillions
of dollars every year with no
repercussions now to play catch-up the
fed has been raising rates and plans to
seven times this year
you are already starting to see those
ripple effects in the housing market as
people's buying power is collapsing have
you considered what could happen in the
stock market if the economy stalls out
do not wait till that happens take some
of the profits from the stock market now
and solidify them with gold from birch
gold throughout history gold has
maintained its value better than any
other investment in the world text
knowles canada w les to 98 98 98 for a
free zero obligation info kit on holding
gold in a tax sheltered retirement
account join the thousands of happy
birch gold customers with countless five
star reviews and a plus rating from the
better business bureau i trust the
professionals at birch gold text knowles
canada wles 298 98 98 i've always
enjoyed investing in precious metals
especially gold secure the gains you've
made while you can go check out birch
gold today
the conspiracy theory there's a crazy
conspiracy theory that that students are
being exposed to pornography in schools
not just pledging allegiance to some
weird sexual ideology but they're actual
pornography that's not true that's not
happening you right wingers are making
this up there was a parent at a colorado
school board meeting
who pulled out a book it's a very
popular book it's in school libraries
across the country the book is called
genderqueer take a listen
these two books that are on the poster
are lawn boy and genderqueer i will say
that i'm i do not favor book banning i
want to tell you that off the bat
but i do want to tell you that
pornography does not belong
in our schools or accessible
to our children
i got a new strap-on harness today i
can't wait to put it on you it will fit
my favorite dildo perfectly i can't wait
to have your car in my mouth i'm going
to give you a job of your life
then i want you inside me sorry you're
out of order this is your first warning
this
this is a book that is that is
accessible in adam's 12.
so kindly refrain from further
reading here please thank you this is
what you allow in our schools and this
is what you allow
for our kids to have access to this is
pornography and this is grooming for
pedophilia
please give me my time back
it's in the schools
it's in the school they say you're out
of order well if i'm out of order why
because i'm reading the book well then
the book is out of order if it's out of
order for adults why on earth would you
expose this to kids who are in our
schools
well i'm sorry that's i'm not going to
answer you it's just that's out of order
the reason that the school board is
upset here
is not because of the obscene content of
the book it's because the parent is
exposing the obscene content of the book
to the people to the parents of this
district who are shocked and appalled by
this as they as they obviously should be
that's just a conspiracy theory though
right uh i don't think so
so all it's all a crazy conspiracy
theory this weird sex stuff is a loser
for democrats the reason that they're so
keen on saying it's a conspiracy theory
and shutting it up and censoring it and
taking away the microphone at the school
board meeting is because they know that
this is a loser at the ballot box it's a
winner in the long term if the left can
totally reshape sexual mores and can
push especially their sexual radicalism
because sex is so important to human
nature then it can really help them to
reshape society so it's a good long-term
strategy if they want to up end society
but it's a really crappy short-term
strategy because people hate it and it's
weird and they want to protect their
kids
this is true not just on the transgender
stuff or the education stuff it's true
in abortion as well joe manchin just
proved me right on this joe manchin
who's a centrist democrat he refused to
go along with the democrats new abortion
law which failed yesterday in the senate
or failed two days ago in the senate
the law we were told
simply tried to codify roe vs wade and
they kept using this phrase codify roe
vs wade because roe vs wade
is a popular enough expression
abortion is not very
popular late term abortion is not
popular at all only six percent of
americans believe that abortion should
be legal at any time during pregnancy
ninety-four percent oppose that
but the phrase roe versus wade because
people don't really know what it means
and it just we've heard it a lot and it
seems fine that phrase is fine so so the
left says the law is going to codify roe
vs wade i told you a few days ago i said
the law does a lot more than codify roe
versus wade it actually gets rid of
virtually every abortion restriction in
the country it's extraordinarily radical
joe manchin just admitted that i was
totally right
the bill we have today to vote on the
women's health protection act and i
respect people who support but don't
make no mistake it is not roe v wade
codification it's an expansion it wipes
500
500 state laws off the books
it expands abortion
and with that
that's not where we are today we should
not be dividing this country further
than were already divided it's it's
really the
the politics
of congress that's dividing the country
it's not the people
they they're telling us what they want
and uh it's just disappointing that
we're going to be voting on a piece of
legislation which i will not vote for
today
it obviously expands roe v wade just
look at the text of the bill it's not
it's not complicated the text of the
bill refers to to transgender men or
women or whatever it refers to
even beyond what it does to abortion
itself it just
uses language and accepts concepts that
are so much more radical and modern than
whatever the supreme court said in 1973
part of which was actually already
overruled in planned parenthood v casey
so much more this is an expansion of
abortion it's a loser for democrats
why is joe manchin voting against it
maybe because he thinks it's it's the
right thing to do to vote against it but
also as he says the people have told him
what they want they don't want this the
abortion bill failed 49 to 51. the
majority of people don't want this okay
the majority of people don't want
abortion on demand without apology the
vast virtually every american wants some
restrictions on abortion and what the
radicals will tell you what the libs
will tell you is they don't care whoopi
goldberg made this point on the view
just yesterday
whoopi goldberg said i do not care what
you think you the people think about
abortion search 71 percent of americans
believe there should be some limitations
on abortion this is forcing a
conversation about limitations but yes
this is an uncomfortable conversation we
have to have at what point does a baby
in the womb have rights listen
it doesn't matter what you think when
you think it is if i don't think that
that's what it is
but listen but everything i don't have
this i don't have to tell you it's not a
business it's your decision yeah what
you do with your body and how your
family works and for me i don't care
what your religious beliefs are it's not
even a religion but it is
this is all based
i don't care what your beliefs are oh
okay whoopi well i don't care what you
don't care about because this last time
i checked is still something resembling
a self-government and i get a say
because i'm an american citizen
we get a say in how our country is
governed
this is always what the libs do that
ultimately the libs who are the the most
most emphatic about stressing their
commitment to democracy and our
democracy
they do not care about democracy when
democracy runs up against liberalism
this is why in eastern europe whenever
eastern european countries elect leaders
that the libs don't like they always say
it's a threat to democracy when the
hungarians elect victor orban they say
this is a threat to democracy what the
hell are you talking about democracy is
when the people vote on something and
the majority of them vote for something
and they get it
that's what happened but no it's a
that's a threat to democracy when the
majority of people vote for something
that the liberals don't like because the
liberals when they say democracy really
just mean
liberalism leftism progressivism
but the
the liberals will cry crocodile tears
about the threat to our sacred temple of
democracy when the horn hat guy shows up
and dances around the capital rotunda
that that's a great terrible dire threat
but then the moment that the people say
no we actually don't want radical
abortion laws all of a sudden democracy
goes out the window and whoopi says i
don't care what you have to say i don't
care what you think and that's always
been the issue with abortion going back
to 1973 when the courts took abortion
out of the legislatures and said no
we're going to pretend that there's a
constitutional right to it
and ever since then up to and especially
including today
the the small group of radicals say we
don't care what you think
and they're willing to upend all of the
institutions of our democracy to do it
big big loser for the libs
but it reminds us of how we have to
react
because for a long time conservatives
backed away from democracy for a long
time conservatives backed away from the
political order and we said okay we're
just going to fight our battles in the
private sector we're just going to fight
our battles in the marketplace
we're not going to wield the government
by which is meant
politics by which is meant our dem our
actual democracy by which it meant the
political power that the framers gave to
us the
people some republicans are beginning to
wake up and figure out what time it is
josh hawley is one of them josh hawley
a u.s senator from missouri is now
threatening to
remove disney's special copyright
protections and to remove major league
baseball's special anti-trust
protections
and he is doing that explicitly because
those two companies are going very woke
so hawley proposed the copyright clause
restoration act which would limit new
copyright protections to 56 years and
retroactively change protections for
companies like disney that quote have
been granted unnecessarily long
copyright monopolies
you saw this copyright term extended in
1998 this was sunny when sonny bono was
a congressman it was the sonny bono
copyright term extension act of 1998 it
was commonly known as the mickey mouse
protection act and disney got a
sweetheart deal on their copyrights
major league baseball has gone super
duper woke in recent years so and and
major league baseball most recently uh
removed the all-star game from georgia
because they wanted to protest georgia's
integrity election integrity laws so
josh hawley says that mlb should lose
its long-standing anti-trust exemption
which no other industry enjoys in the
same way
there are going to be some people who
who whine and complain and say this is
the use of the government to target
private corporations this is terrible
this is awful this is
this is
politics folks this is self-government
there's nothing anti-conservative or
unprincipled or un-american about it
this is we the people saying no we're
not going to let giant
usually multinational corporations wield
their massive political power to
completely upend the american way of
life
when you're talking about something like
copyright when you're talking about the
the mickey mouse copyright protection
act or something and josh hawley trying
to get rid of some of disney's special
protections
there's an argument for it and there's
an argument against it i think
reasonable people can disagree
over
copyright law and how long copyrights
should exist and what copyrights should
be in movies compared to books compared
to i think reasonable people can
disagree about that i think reasonable
people can disagree about what sort of
special protections big sports leagues
should get
okay there's
this is not just a purely ideological
manner matter where you just write down
three bullet points on the back of a
napkin and this is true conservatism and
this is true progressivism no it's
politics folks politics is a big sphere
where we can discuss how we want to live
and where we the people can push back
against the extreme radical predations
of
of
business leaders who are frankly acting
like oligarchs but here's what i'll tell
you
here's what i will tell you when the
people even when they just saber rattle
a little bit when we the people say we
are willing to go after woke
corporations
it works breaking news at a variety the
trade paper in hollywood
netflix updates its corporate culture
memo adding anti-censorship section and
vowing to spend our members money wisely
so they came out they that netflix has
said look we're we're not gonna we're
not gonna go woke okay we're not going
to and especially they said we are not
going to cave to our woke employees
which is what happened to disney over
the the parental rights and education
law
they said artistic expression
we have a new section called artistic
expression they will not quote censor
specific artists or voices even if
employees consider that content harmful
they say if you'd find it hard to
support our content breadth
netflix may not be the best place for
you
so they're telling their woke employees
go pound sand we're not going to deal
with this this is in part because there
was a giant woke netflix uproar over a
dave chappelle special last year
but i think what this is really about is
disney i think that if the florida
legislature and governor ron desantis
had not gone after disney and not taken
away disney's special tax exemptions and
not not specifically gone after disney
after disney specifically went after the
voters of florida i don't think you
would see this from netflix right now
i think if you weren't seeing political
actions like josh hawley saying you know
disney
you done messed up disney you just
you just pushed it a little too far
disney and now we're going to make an
example of you because we are not going
to stand idly by while you groom our
freaking kids in your weird lgbt lmnop
transgender nonsense
we're not gonna we're gonna use
everything that we the people still have
we don't have the media we don't have
the educational institutions we don't
have big tech we don't have we don't
have we don't have anything we don't
have the government bureaucracy we have
very very little but we do still have a
little bit of a vote in our legislatures
and we're going to use that power and
we're going to say no
and we're going to make life real
unpleasant for you
and if you're netflix over here frankly
the ceo of netflix is probably happy to
see that happen to disney because this
gives the ceo of netflix some cover say
yo guys we're just not gonna do it okay
we can't we can't afford to do it
we're getting way too much pushback the
reason that the the libs cave all the
time the reason that the vote
corporations cave rather to the libs is
because they say look we just can't take
the pressure
we can't take the threats we can't take
the boycotts we can't take the walkouts
well how about we we conservatives bring
a little bit of pressure too in a
completely moral and principled and
political way i think that's a great
idea this is great news from netflix
good job florida republicans good job
josh hawley
keep it up
when we see the culture when we see
private enterprise private business
doing
this woke virtue signaling
it's more than just silly
it's more sometimes it's just disgusting
and disordered and and needs to be
discouraged as best we can calvin klein
did this today
calvin klein used to put out ads that
were you know kind of saucy kind of
scintillating
i don't think they were exactly obscene
but you know calvin klein you know it's
they
make underwear right they so obviously
they want to
put forward an image of men and women
that is attractive
until recently until they've gone woke
and now they're selling their products
by posting a picture it's it's become
the meme it's the meme of that emoji
it's a pregnant man
ostensibly it's a it's an image of what
looks like a woman
lying with what sort of looks like a man
it's someone with a beard and a buzz cut
but a big pregnant belly and so you
realize oh no this is a this is a woman
who has cut her breasts off and is now
exposing her mutilated breasts
and taken a bunch of cross-sex hormones
and is pregnant with a baby and so we're
going to show you this topless confused
woman in our ads to sell underwear the
the caption is today in support of women
and mothers around the world we
highlight the reality of new families
the uh k vensel is a south african
painter and mother to wild erica fee and
roberto beet are expecting parents from
brazil roberto is due to give birth to
his and erica's son noah any day now
vanenda carter
carter is a prominent fashion consultant
her family's bobby and weston
this is wrong
it's wrong can we say it's wrong i know
we're not it's not politically correct
to say that we're not we're supposed to
keep our opinions to ourselves and we'll
be called bigots and phobes and all it's
it's wrong right it's worse it's
disgusting
it is disgusting
that our culture is celebrating women
mutilating their own bodies
and then
redefining all of the most basic human
institutions
and
putting children in a very bad position
and depriving them of their natural
mothers and fathers in many cases all to
satisfy our sexual delusions and desires
and fetishes it's wrong and disgusting
and the culture should discourage it and
stop it and say no
are we allowed to say that am i allowed
to i know that's
contradicting every work orthodoxy that
we're now told and yet we all know it's
true we all know it if you showed that
that picture that advertisement
to
100 americans at random 99 and a half of
them would say stop this what on earth
are you doing and what does the ad say
it says today in support of women and
mothers around the world we highlight
the reality of new families
i i don't accept this new definition of
family
do you do you
one there's no limiting principle on it
so there's no definition at all
if we can redefine the family
in this way if we can redefine the
family away from what it actually is
which is mommy and daddy love each other
very much and do that thing that married
people do and that creates a baby if we
can redefine it away from that to say
well it's mommy and
mommy and mommy and mommy daddy and
daddy daddy and daddy and daddy's friend
and a goat if we get what's the limiting
principle there isn't one
and it totally throws open the quote
what is a family what is a family for
what does a family do what distinguishes
a family from a town or a city or a
nation
well the complementarity of the sexes
and the the possibility of creating life
that's that's what distinguishes it as
an as a natural fact okay do we have the
right in this country to stand up for
that
the supreme court tells us no
the
bureaucracy tells us no the radical
activists tell us no but i think we do i
think we still have some political
rights and whoopi goldberg and corrine
jean-pierre and the the people who run
our country and who speak for the people
who run our country they're going to
laugh at us and tell us that they don't
give a damn what we think but i think we
still have some political rights and i
think we have not only the right but a
responsibility
to assert those rights
it is the most infamous supreme court
case in memory it's the deadliest
decision in history even 50 years after
roe versus wade few people know the
truth behind the landmark decision
the decision that has enabled the
slaughter of 64 million babies since
1971.
daily wire is taking a wrecking ball to
the four big lies that the abortion
industry was built upon with our
original documentary choosing death the
legacy of roe we will uncover the inside
story of how roe v wade came to pass and
why it needs to pass away some of this
content is hard to take in few subjects
if any are more important here's the
trailer
um many times when we
did this
as we started
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus it was too late to stop
i was handing hush money
to women who we had left pieces of their
baby
we had put these women's lives in
jeopardy we'd put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for 800
and for a poor woman 800 is a lot of
money
i mean there have been so many moments
in the last decade plus of going
undercover in abortion clinics myself
and seeing
just heartbreaking things women vomiting
in the hallway of an abortion clinic
crying out in pain
the late term abortionist talking
casually
about how they would literally leave a
born alive baby to die or if you deliver
the baby in the toilet then you pick it
up and stuff it in a plastic bag and
bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit
they are being drowned
um their necks are being snapped
it's it's happening more often than
people want to think about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women
and you're just you're realizing it
you're watching in front of your own
eyes play out america's greatest horror
story
which is
how we butcher children
in the name of choice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
help us to expose the truth tell your
friends to watch if you've not already
done it become a daily wire member tune
in today to watch our documentary on
abortion choosing death the legacy of
roe go to dailywire.com
choosing and join the fight today we
will be right back with the mailbag
sponsored by puretalk
i am so excited to debut our brand new
segment the voicemail bag oh boy we are
catching up with the technology folks
pretty soon we're gonna have a fax
machine in here this is i love that we
have got i'm gonna get to hear from you
within your own voices and the the
reason that we can do this is because of
pure talk get unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data for just thirty dollars
a month go to puretalk.com enter promo
code noel's podcast to save 50 off your
first month today let's get started give
me the first voicemail
hey michael my name is braden and i am a
pro-life conservative just like you
how would you respond to somebody that
challenges you on abortion when they say
that if republicans care so much about
the baby when they're in the womb why
don't they give just as much care to
that baby when they're out of the womb
basically
what do we do to prove to mothers and
parents
that we as republicans or we as
conservatives do care about the baby
even after it's born just as much as we
care about the life when it's in the
womb
thanks love the show
great question you you actually can't do
anything to prove it to them because
they they don't want it to be proved to
them because they don't even really mean
what they're saying
because the answer to the question is
we do care about the babies when they
get out of the womb we care about them
much more than the democrats do
republicans conservatives are much more
likely to adopt than democrats are
republicans and conservatives are much
more likely to give to charity than
democrats are so that's just
that's self-evident okay
second
the two questions have nothing to do
with one another
your views on
government welfare your views on private
charity your views on schooling for
children your views on how to reform the
welfare system those are important
questions but they have absolutely
nothing to do with your views on whether
or not it is right to kill a baby
they're totally separate issues
it would be like saying hey look you
guys you you guys keep talking about how
we should have laws against murder right
you think it should be illegal to murder
people but you don't want to even
increase
that other tax credit that i want
so if you don't want to increase a tax
credit that i want then we can't have
laws against murder what are you talking
about those two things have absolutely
nothing to do with one another
but but
i go back to my first point
i don't think the argument is really
worth engaging because it's not real
it's just a way to distract
it's just a way when you say hey hey
democrats we shouldn't kill babies right
they're like look over there hey is that
a butterfly hey hey what's going on it's
just it's a complete distraction and so
you can gently brush it aside you say
republicans care very much about babies
actually
whatever statistics we've got on it
shows we care more than you guys do i
mean just look at what we're in right
now the republicans are trying
desperately to pass laws and to get
answers as to why there's a baby formula
shortage and how to fix it and the
democrats are laughing about the baby
formula shortage and then sending what
little baby formula we have down to the
border to give to foreign nationals so
there you have it you've got your answer
right there
next voice mail bag
hello mr nostradamus this is camille
from your mailbag
i'm honored to be heard on your show if
this were to get played my question is
yet again about dating
i'm still single guys if you're out
there anyway my question is i was
talking to a guy friend of mine about
how long a guy is willing to wait
to sleep with a girl and he said that he
wouldn't wait any longer than a month
and i used to think that maybe we'd be
more than friends but after hearing that
is that something that is a deal breaker
is it something that could be reconciled
because i definitely would like to wait
so i would just love to hear your
thoughts if that is a deal breaker or if
you think that maybe he can be changed
or things could be changed down the road
thanks love the show
i can change him you can change him
it's up to him as to whether or not
that's a deal breaker
it's up to you to just say no
and i've got a little secret for you
camille
men like to be told no
we do we don't like when it's just easy
to get whatever we want forget even
outside of dating in professional life
in in anything
we like a little bit of a challenge we
like to be told no
we we don't like when things are easy
that's what girls i don't think they
really use this phrase anymore but girls
used to be called easy and guys didn't
really guys liked girls that were easy
for a night or two but didn't like girls
that were easy to think of in the long
term so tell them no say like well all
right listen you
degenerate uh no you're not gonna get me
that easy and if you if you want it then
you should have put a ring on it and uh
so if you want a date we can date but if
you don't then okay go enjoy your
hussies and see what he says i bet he'll
probably be interested and if he's not
then too bad for him good for you that
you've avoided this derelict and maybe
he'll reform and i i suspect he will in
the long run but that's that's not your
problem in the short run what you've got
to do is is what is right right in the
short run what you've got to do is not
only what is right but apparently what
you want to do as well
and don't let some dirtbag try to
pressure you all right next voicemail
bag
hey michael my name's johnny i was
wondering what your opinion is on women
in combat arms
great short question wow and a really
good question too
i'm against it
i don't i think it's a bad idea
i am not against it merely because women
are not capable of fighting in combat i
suspect there are lots of women who are
capable of fighting in combat not as
many as the libs would have us believe
the libs want us to believe that men and
women are exactly the same and so
therefore there's no reason to prevent
women from doing anything in the
military but i suspect that there are
some women who could do certain jobs in
combat especially now that combat is
less
it's still about it but it's less about
brute strength and there there is a more
nuance to combat because we live in a
very technological age
but i'm against it for a different
reason i'm against it because
it's just wrong it's just disordered
it's just unseemly because men are
supposed to protect women because i
think men and women are different and
men have a role to protect women and
women have their own roles and women are
are more nurturing
than men are women have roles to
obviously to take care of the family to
take care of the community in a
different way because when men see that
women are in danger and in trouble
they're going to they just naturally are
going to go and protect that woman
and even if that would compromise
perhaps some aspects of their mission
and their operation what they're
actually trying to do
because of the intractable you're n
you're simply not going to get over it
or redefine a difference between men and
women
women have different places you always
always hear now about rape in the
military and i have no doubt that there
is a problem of rape in the military one
of the reasons that there's a problem of
rape in the military
is because
men and women are being put in these
extremely close quarters all the time
and women are being exposed to the
danger of rape in the military and i
don't think that's a good idea and what
the what the feminists will tell you is
we'll just teach men not to rape will or
or on the other side just teach men not
to go give special protection to women
or just teach men not to care that men
and women are different well that
all i'm telling you is these are facts
of human nature and some of them are
ugly facts and some of them are
beautiful facts but these are facts of
human nature
if it's raining outside you should use
an umbrella
well just tell the clouds to stop
raining no i'm just i'm just telling you
a fact of things that are going to
happen okay and some of them are ugly
facts like sexual assault that could
occur in the military some of them are
beautiful facts like the fact that men
are generally more protective and
uh and aggressive in the face of a foe
and women are more nurturing that's a
beautiful thing too
it all boils down to
men and women are different it's not
evil and wrong for them to have
different roles in society certainly not
certainly in the military and
it's it is simply not the case as the
feminists contend that the only way for
women to be strong and important and
virtuous is to pretend to be men i just
don't think that's the case next
voicemail back
hey michael my name is heather myself
along with my husband and three small
children are going to be moving to
nashville in the beginning of june we're
super pumped and hey maybe we'll run
into you
at trader joe's sometime but my question
is in regards to
this roe v wade ruling of the supreme
court which i really hope uh goes
through but anyways i've got some more
liberal friends on social media that are
obviously trying to say that this is
going to make
abortion you know illegal across the
united states and it's going to be such
an attack on women and women's rights
even though it was you know their choice
to engage in sexual activities with the
possible outcome of having a child
anyways um you know how do i respond to
those same women who are so gung-ho on
killing
children
when they finally get pregnant and then
want to call this thing growing inside
them a miracle baby that they get to
have with their family because now they
want it and it's convenient
um i'm obviously always happy for new
life to come into the world but
i've been getting very bitter about this
entire situation so i'd love for you to
shed some light on how to handle all of
this with love thanks michael
really good question i have heard from
a number of my female friends
and female relatives
who are
furious
at their other friends and relatives who
have babies
who who will post a picture on social
media of them with their babies playing
with their cute little babies and then
the very next picture they'll post is
how we need to defend roe v wade and how
we need to defend a woman's right to
choose and they they get really angry
about the obvious disconnect
between how they view their own baby and
how they view other people's babies and
they get really angry i don't get really
angry about it it's preposterous it's
absurd it saddens me sometimes it even
kind of amuses me in a dark way that
that people could be this stupid this
obtuse
but i don't really get that angry about
it
when it comes to the issue of abortion
people are defending killing little
babies it is no surprise that people who
are defending killing little babies
might be kind of confused might not be
seeing things very clearly and so i just
remain calm about that i think this is a
fallen world i think that the world has
practiced human sacrifice from the very
beginning so i'm not surprised i feel
some moral outrage about it no question
about that i would like to do everything
i can to stop that but i i don't allow
myself to get angry this is just a fact
of the world
ignorance moral confusion
frankly even human sacrifice these are
facts of a fallen world and so
accepting that
i think we can calmly just
if you even want to have that
conversation if your friend is not just
spouting off on some stupid little
facebook tangent but is actually
interested in this issue
just say hey
when was your baby a baby
and a very often what the women will say
is well look i would never get an
abortion i would never get an abortion
but i understa i understand that other
other women would and should have that
right
ah but i would never get one the next
question is why would you never get one
because the the answer really deep down
is well i would never kill my precious
progeny but all those poor black people
in the inner cities they should
that's what they're saying that's the oh
well you know people who are like poor
or you know they kind of they they live
in bad places or they are
disproportionately racial minorities
they definitely don't want to admit that
part uh yeah they should because it's
like
yucky you know
it's bad it's bad to live in the bad
places but then they're not gonna you
know so let's just
no that's what they're saying and they
just they're not aware that they're
saying that so i think
if if your friends are not
particularly philosophical or not
thinking about this in a really
objective way and you do want to have
that conversation maybe just start with
them why would you not do it well if you
would not do it because you don't want
to kill your own baby why shouldn't we
have a law about that we have all sorts
of laws about
that's what a law is right it's telling
people how to behave so if we have laws
about where you can park why shouldn't
we have laws about who you can kill
all right next voicemail back hey
michael listen i'm not a misogynist let
me put that out of the way first but i
just want to know what is your opinion
as to why women have gotten so picky and
entitled when it comes to finding a man
some of them will say that they won't
date anyone who's under six foot five
some won't date anyone that makes under
20 billion dollars a year and someone
date anyone that doesn't look like
leonardo dicaprio why have women become
like this i think it's kind of unfair
where if i say i don't want to date a
woman that's fat i'm all of a sudden a
misogynist and that is my only parameter
of women i'm not going to date
so yeah why do you think women became
like this and how can we kind of change
that because there's too many women on
my timeline complaining about not
finding men but doing this at the same
time thank you
i knew this was going to be a good
question when it opened with look i'm
not a misogynist to nothing but
how come i can't say that a woman's fat
and i don't want to date her but she can
uh you know i think
men and women have always had a little
bit of a problem understanding one
another they've wanted different things
it's always good first to take a look at
the man in the mirror and see there's
maybe something wrong on your side but
you are identifying a real problem that
i think is actually particular today you
see people delaying getting married you
see people dating lots more people
before they ever settle down i think the
reason for that is swipe right culture
i think the reason for that is not just
women but men too
are are viewing one another as uh
expendable are viewing one another as
replaceable as and of course because the
way we date now is we just look on a
phone and everyone looks pretty much you
know they're all in the same context and
we just go boom boom boom boom boom and
there's an endless supply of them and
and so
this is one of the it's how people date
now so i'm not discouraging it entirely
but this is one of the perils of online
dating is that you you just you reduce
people to their individual features
their height their looks their
their hair color or their whatever
their resume even that they put on some
of these personals ads on the dating
apps and you don't look at a human being
as a cohesive whole as something special
something
something and someone that is unique and
get to know them and so it's just i got
it one date monday one day tuesday one
day thursday and you keep you keep
moving on no you're talking to real
human beings recognize that you're
dealing with eternal people and you're
gonna have to see those people in heaven
someday if you're lucky buster okay i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin